un professeur aujourd'hui que dans des
conditions particulièrement affreuse et
après ça passe et 3 et après les chaînes
d'information on parle 24 heures sur 24
les gouvernements font des successifs
font des déclarations martiales et après
le soufflé retombe et on ne gagnera pas
comme ça moi j'ai entendu bien des
ministres puis 2014 et des présidents de
la république dire on est en guerre
c'est la guerre
et si on fait la guerre on l'a fait si
on est vraiment en guerre ce que je
pense et ce que les français pensent
d'ailleurs un français moyen ne peut pas
comprendre qu'un imam étrangers en
france qui prêchent la haine contre la
démocratie qui prêchent l'inégalité
hommes femmes etc
et bien finalement il continue à prêcher
et qu'on ne puisse rien faire même pas
l'expulser dans son propre pays appelant
les personnes radicaliser qui donc sur
des gens qui représentent un danger
disons pour les lois de la république on
a quatre mille étrangers
on pourrait probablement en expulser un
certain nombre ce qui permettrait déjà
de diminuer le nombre de personnes à
surveiller
et ce qui faciliterait quand même le
travail des services de renseignement on
devrait être capables tous autour de la
table musulmans chrétiens juifs de
l'extrême gauche à l'extrême droite en
passant par le centre de se mettre
d'accord sur au moins un certain nombre
de points communs
la défense de la laïcité l'égalité
hommes femmes face des choses qui nous
paraissent évidentes on voit bien qu'il
ya quand même un certain nombre de
personnes qui ne sont pas d'accord avec
la laïcité avec l'égalité hommes-femmes
ou ou qui préférant des alliances un
petit peu contre nature
moi venons juste à me poser un problème
il faut avoir une volonté politique
c'est pour ça qu'il est mou sont
importants mais derrière j'ai entendu
une mise d'intérieur qui disait nous
allons expulser un certain nombre de
personnes
j'ai tout lieu de l'écouter et de le
croire je pense qu'il est dynamique
après ce que je veux ce que je souhaite
comme tout le monde finalement ce sont
des résultats
moi je souhaite pas que s'installe le
match il mêle macron contre marine le
pen
je pense qu'il ya une place pour la
gauche républicaine
il ya une place pour la droite
républicaine nous nous avons un parti
nous avons des élus nous avons dit
jean nous avons dix départements nous
avons des adhérents nous avons des idées
pour l'instant nous n'avons pas encore
mais ça viendra
le champion